MARIA: WELCOME BACK BREAKING
NEWS THIS MORNING ON A STORY
THAT WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING A
PROFESSOR AT CASE WESTERN
RESERVE UNIVERSITY IN CLEVELAND
HAS BEEN ARRESTED OVER HIS
ALLEGED FINANCIAL TIES TO CHINA.
THIS JUST DAYS AFTER THE FBI
SOUNDED THE ALARM ON CHINA’S
ATTEMPT TO STEAL CORONAVIRUS
RESEARCH.
A PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARKANSAS WAS ARRESTED ON SIMILAR
CHARGES LAST WEEK, AND THEN IN
JANUARY, HARVARD’S CHEMISTRY
CHIEF WAS CHARGED WITH FAILING
TO DISCLOSE HE TOO WAS BEING
PAID BY THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
TWO WEEKS AGO SENATOR TOM COTTON
TOLD US THAT THE  CCP WAS TRYING
IN MANY WAYS TO STEAL MEDICAL
DATA FROM THE UNITED STATES TO
COME UP WITH A VACCINE FOR
COVID-19 BEFORE THE UNITED
STATES.
MY SETDOWN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
INCLUDED THIS.
WE DISCUSSED IP THEFT AND THE
PANDEMIC’S IMPACT OF HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA AND
XI-JINPING.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO SAID HE HAD
STRONG EVIDENCE IT DID COME FROM
THE LAB.
WE’VE BEEN REPORTING THIS EVERY
SUNDAY BY THE WAY FROM EARLY ON.
YOU ALSO SAID THAT YOU SAW
EVIDENCE.
CAN YOU TELL US ANYTHING ABOUT
THE INTELLIGENCE?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: NO BUT WE HAVE
A LOT OF INFORMATION, AND IT’S
NOT GOOD, BUT YOU KNOW THE WORST
OF ALL WHETHER IT CAME FROM THE
LAB OR  CAME FROM THE BATS,
IT ALL CAME FROM CHINA, AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE STOPPED IT.
THEY COULD HAVE STOPPED IT AT
THAT SOURCE.
I CALL IT THE SOURCE.
RIGHT THERE.
MARIA: BUT HIS DECISION TO ALLOW
IT TO ESCAPE ITS BORDERS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I DON’T KNOW IF
THEY MADE THE DECISION BUT IT
GOT OUT OF CONTROL.
I THINK MORE LIKELY IT GOT OUT
OF CONTROL.
MARIA: SENATOR COTTON SAID THEY
DIDN’T WANT THE CHINESE ECONOMY
TO CONTRACT 20% AND THE REST OF
THE WORLD TO CONTRACT 2%.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: SO WE WERE
BEATING THEM VERY BADLY BEFORE
THIS.
WE WERE BEATING THEM BETWEEN THE
TARIFFS AND OTHER THINGS WE
WERE DOING, AND WE WERE GOING UP
AND THEY WERE HAVING A VERY BAD
YEAR.
THEY WERE HAVING THE WORST YEAR
THEY’VE HAD IN 56 YEARS.
MARIA: AND THEY HAD PROTESTERS
ON THE STREETS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: BEYOND THAT WE
WERE DOING WELL, HERE IS WHAT I
KNOW FOR SURE.
THEY DIDN’T ALLOW THIS WHOLE
THING, THEY DIDN’T ALLOW PEOPLE
TO GO INTO CHINA, BUT THEY DID
ALLOW THEM TO GO OUT TO THE
WORLD INCLUDING THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT’S WHY EUROPE IS A MESS.
THAT’S WHY LOOK AT THESE
COUNTRIES.
RUSSIA IS HAVING A HARD TIME.
EVERYBODY IS HAVING A HARD TIME.
MARIA: WILL IT GET WORSE FOR
THOSE COUNTRIES DO YOU THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP: FOR SOME OF
THEM.
SOME HAVE JUST STARTED THE
PROCESS.
WE’RE GETTING TOWARD THE END OF
THE PROCESS.
MARIA: SO THEY DOWNPLAYED THE
DISEASE AND THE VIRUS, AT
THE SAME TIME, THEY’RE ALLOWING
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL, 5 MILLION
PEOPLE LEAVING WUHAN GOING TO
ITALY AND THE UNITED STATES, AND
THEN THEY START CORNERING THE
MARKET ON PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT EVEN THOUGH CHINA IS
ALREADY BEING THE LARGEST
PRODUCER OF THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THAT’S NOT THE
BIG THING.
LOOK THE BIG THING IS THEY
SHOULD HAVE NEVER LET THIS
HAPPEN SO MAKE A GREAT
TRADE DEAL AND NOW I SAY, IT
JUST DOESN’T FEEL THE SAME TO ME
THE INK WAS BARELY DRY AND THE
PLAGUE CAME OVER AND IT
DOESN’T FEEL THE SAME TO ME.
MARIA: ARE THEY GOING TO BUY THE
250 BILLION ARE THEY?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY WILL BUY
250, 250 BILLION, THEY SAID
SOMEWHERE I SEE THEY’D LIKE TO
RENEGOTIATE THE DEAL.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO RENEGOTIATE.
LOOK, I’M NOT HAPPY ABOUT
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THAT
PARTICULAR SUBJECT RIGHT NOW.
MARIA: HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO
XI-JINPING?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I HAVE A VERY
GOOD RELATIONSHIP BUT I JUST
RIGHT NOW I DON’T WANT TO SPEAK
TO HIM.
MARIA: BECAUSE SENATOR COTTON
WAS SAYING MAYBE WE SHOULD BE
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF VISAS
THAT WE GIVE TO STUDENTS WHO
WANT TO STUDY THINGS LIKE
COMPUTERS AND AI.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THERE ARE MANY
THINGS WE COULD DO.
WE COULD CUTOFF THE WHOLE
RELATIONSHIP.
NOW IF YOU DID, WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN?
YOU’D SAVE $500 BILLION.
IF YOU CUTOFF THE WHOLE
RELATIONSHIP, LOOK, AT WHAT
POINT DOES IT AND I SAID THIS
FOR YEARS I SAID IT WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES ALSO.
YOU KNOW, CHINA’S NOT THE ONLY
COUNTRY RIPPING US OFF.
AT NATO, WHERE WE DEFEND EUROPE
BY THE WAY, FOR ESSENTIALLY
NOTHING I WAS ABLE TO GET THEM
TO PAY HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MORE.
YOU KNOW MY BIGGEST FAN OF THE
WORLD?
SECRETARY STOLTENBERG.
HE’S BEEN THERE A LONG TIME AND
SAID NOBODY HAS EVER GOTTEN, YOU
KNOW WE WERE PAYING MORE AND YOU
HAVE TO SEE THE CHART OF WHAT
THEY PAY.
SO WE ARE DEFENDING EUROPE AND
THEN THEY’RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
US ON TRADE.
IT’S ALL ONE WAY AND IT WAS ALL
TURNING AND IT IS ALL TURNING
AROUND.
MARIA: AND YOU PULLED BACK THE
MONEY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: BUT PROVEN TO
BE RIGHT.
YEAH, I PULLED BACK THE MONEY.
MARIA: THEY WANTED TO PUT 10% OF
THE THRIFT FUND INTO SCIENCE
COMPANIES $50 BILLION.
WILL YOU GO ONE STEP FURTHER AND
FORCE THE CHINESE COMPANIES HAVE
TO FOLLOW ACCOUNTING RULES IF
THEY WANT TO BE LISTED ON THE
NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE’RE LOOKING
AT THAT VERY STRONGLY BUT ON THE
THRIFT FUND YOU KNOW IT’S
RUN BY THE OBAMA APPOINTMENTS
RIGHT?
AND WE SAID YOU GOT TO DO THIS
AND WE’RE GOING TO FIND OUT
WHETHER OR  NOT THEY DO IT VERY
SOON AND IF THEY AREN’T WE’RE
GOING TO REPLACE THEM VERY
QUICKLY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT YOUR SECOND
PART OF YOUR QUESTION, WE’RE
LOOKING AT THAT.
MARIA: BECAUSE CHINESE COMPANIES
THEY’RE LISTED ON THE NEW YORK
STOCK EXCHANGE THEY DON’T HAVE
TO REPORT THEIR EARNINGS THE WAY
AN AMERICAN COMPANY DOES?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: PRETTY AMAZING
BUT HERE IS THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
LOOK I HATE TO SAY IT, BUT LET’S
SAY WE DO THAT RIGHT?
SO WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
THEY WILL MOVE THEIR LISTING TO
LONDON OR  SOME PLACE ELSE, DO
YOU SEE?
LET’S SAY YOU WANT TO GET TOUGH
AND YOU ARE GOING TO, YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE WANTS TO BE A TOUGH GUY
LOOK I’M THE TOUGHEST GUY BUT
WHAT HAPPENS IS SO WE SAY YOU’RE
GOING TO DO THIS AND YOU’RE
GOING TO FOLLOW THE RULES OF THE
NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE OR
NASDAC.
WHAT DO THEY DO?